.
- Le dernier acte d'une histoire
dont la conclusion est attendue
avec impatience. Le témoignage
du premier ministre du Canada;
ultime témoin de la Commission
sur l'état d'urgence.
Mesures de sécurité accrues,
gens du public et membres
de la presse; tout est en place
pour entendre Justin Trudeau
justifier sa décision
d'invoquer la Loi su
les mesures d'urgence.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- On voyait qu'il y avait
une intensité potentielle, qui
était là pendant la campagne
électorale.
- Des craintes qui se sont
avérées.
(klaxons)
Il y a le blocage d'une
aue àe àe àe à Coutts, en Alber,
où la GRC finira par découvrir
une cache d'armes et où le SCRS
a identifié des manifestants
aux idéologies extrémistes
violentes. S'ajoute à cela la
barricade du pont Ambassador à
Windsor, la présence d'enfants
qui auraient pu servir de
boucliers humains et des corps
policiers, dans certains cas,
dépassés par les évènements.
- Il y avait une urgence d'agir
et que l'outil qu'on avait pour
ramener rapidement ces outils
spécifiques, c'était la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence
- Il y avait pourtant ce plan
d'intervention qui impliquait
différents corps policiers et
qui, selon la commissaire de
la GRC, aurait pu éviter
le recours à la Loi sur
les mesures d'ur
(en anglais)
"Je conseille aux gens de
regarder ce plan, qui,
en fait, n'en était pas un",
affirme Justin Trudeau.
"Mais le document est caviardé",
fait valoir l'avocat
de la Canadian Constitution
Foundation.
"Vous dites que nous devrions
lire ce plan, vous serez
d'accord que nous ne pouvons
pas le faire."
Justin Trudeau ajoute qu'il y
avait consensus au sein de
son cabinet et entre
les conseiécécécécécécurité
et du SCRS.
"Le devoir d'un premier ministre
est de prendre des décisions
difficiles et d'assurer la
sécurité de la population."
Après avoir entendu 76 témoins
en 31 jours, la Commission
tiendra la semaine prochaine
des tables rondes avec
des experts pour discuter,e e es
policiers et de liberté
d'expression. La conclusion
appartiendra ensuite
au commissaire Rouleau.
Son rapport finauuuuuuu
au plus tard le 6 février.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw